hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay just kill the
big guy I'll push the button I don't
know what I did but I pushed it I pushed
it good
Oh get away those things really looks
like it's smashed into the ceiling or
something
actually I don't know really know why
that would hurt so bad
just grabbing right maybe that bad who's
out there oh oh oh what happened to your
other arm yeah yeah did you like to
sneak up behind me are you dead right
now
I'll trust anyone no one not even that
black guy Hammond I entrust Kendra I
don't even trust myself
I don't even just Isaac come on oh yeah
at the end of this game is secretly
Isaac's the bad guy he's the one who's
the most religiously fanatical he's the
one to secure the marker it's so perfect
it's the perfect crime
long elevator it's going to be something
entertaining
come from buddy huh who also walsim
anybody
don't have balls like a lot of saw
another one
there you are
ah you lost your pad
ah
stop no-oh-oh set up another one Oh
missed me by a mile
oh that supposed to be a challenge
oh I'm so Lea look at all this holy Ajay
did is that one more
who wants Shawn
oh so bad tight who's gonna sneak up on
me in the store
anybody oh don't even try okay uh uh
contact me what's the content heavy
damage energy projector seems interstate
I don't need it I don't even do claim
fuel no don't need it don't need it
don't need it you know what I need pulse
round oh yeah give me cause ya all hate
me right now that I don't what happened
wait
I bought Ahmet I found a medkit
schematic where is it good night didn't
I I thought I did maybe I didn't and
though this is a big idiot probably I
wouldn't be surprised
oh man I'm gonna be so pro at this
assault rifle it's gonna be maxed down
all the upgrades everything perfect
where am I going oh I want to talk to my
friend down in there
you know I don't even know why I went to
that other place one level how do I know
what level where's my journal
oh no it says go down okay I'll go down
on level 2 there we go oh yeah
Isaac listen up I've gone over the red
Spy reports these things are bio
recombinator score they take dead tissue
absorbent and molded into new forms one
iteration seems to have the sole purpose
of infecting corpses the others well
Indonesian corpses to infect this one
dead body tissue we keep seeing on the
walls as part of it too I found a report
that says it's a habitat changer UK it's
if you've ever seen the movie the thing
either one a newer version of the older
version it's like that and the thing the
original thing is great whether you see
that the prequel the newer one is a
prequel but it's not as good I don't
need to say oh this looks good
don't trust you don't trust it ah ah I
knew not to trust you it's here alright
that blew up boom boom
can I get out there no no I cannot
okay how's a big wasted Tom okay Oh an
upgrade now close the door give me err
err err thank you
okay um I don't think I have anything
else stuff once again I don't know
Oh so gonna upgrade my god
there's to upgrade damage upgrades left
I'll I'll hold off maybe I'll get a
lucky and get like a double power nut
happen some of you might know because
some of you might have played this game
but I don't know
take all read if you're learning to
complete your sentences guy oh what's
that
no no get body thinks this comes these
guys up good there we go hey aren't you
dead
yeah take a head I got a blade here
there we go ugly bones you hardcore
ponies elders good hard come for lunch
fail I'll trust you
nope don't even try
like maybe a collectible I must have
been a reason for yes might be important
I got gamer intuition about these things
and if not oh don't step on that okay
gimme your dirty
gimme your goodies yari gave up sorry
for stomping on oh yes yes please give
me goodies oh oh yeah yep yep yep yeah
Oh 5,000 now that almost recoups the
cost of it right there and a gold I
think that was a gold semiconductor
that's 3,000 credits right there oh man
they're totally worth it alright why did
I come in why did I come hello I want
tangle with me I'm untangling
oh hello baby get out of here ah switch
to the other weapons - you swing by or
did I just break the rules am I not
allowed to switch to that weapon I don't
know I haven't read the comments since
the last episode because I'm recording
these sequentially now I'll stick to the
rules
I play give game you rogue alright to
the ad okay
control system struction box rerouted
hard it 80s kaolin there who's out there
I'm gonna getting themselves killed on
the gravity plates yep I saw a splat I
don't even need a chute because it
really worked for me
ha OH stumble this way buddy
stand up come on charge come at me bro
come at me bro on
give me one of your friends Oh what up
what up what up
I thought these black ones are supposed
to be tougher oh not even a little bit
not even a little bit there I'm doing
okay actually I have to cut it here
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you you you in the next part
bye bye